well accused sexual predator Nathan
chasing horse in court today but the
Dances with Wolves actor case is pretty
much still at a standstill 8 news now
investigator Vanessa Murphy explains why
from the Regional Justice Center
the case against Nathan chasing horse
here in Clark County District Court
remains on hold while he's waiting for
the Nevada Supreme Court's decision he
is asking the Nevada Supreme Court to
drop the charges against him in the
meantime he remains in custody here in
downtown Las Vegas his court appearance
Wednesday brief at this point I will
continue with that do another status
truck in 45 days Nathan chasing horse
mouthing what appears to be I love you
to his supporters in the courtroom he's
charged with 18 counts after two women
say he sexually assaulted them in Clark
County as first reported by the 8 news
now investigators his attorney public
defender Christy Holston filed this
appeal Tuesday Halston argues
prosecutors failed to present evidence
that either of the women said no in an
exclusive interview one of those alleged
victims Karena Leone told us chasing
horse began sexually abusing her at the
age of 14 and continued to abuse her for
years until she escaped he's evil and he
is manipulative and he is a narcissist
and he knowingly does what he does and
he doesn't have any remorse for it
what he did he knows what he did and
what happened there was rape and there's
no other label to put on it chasing
horses scheduled to be back in court
here on June 21st is for a status check
that's for both the defense and
prosecutors to check in also acknowledge
whether the Nevada Supreme Court made
its decision reporting in downtown Las
Vegas Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now
chasing horse was initially charged with
19 counts but the Clark County District
Court Judge Carly Kearney dropped a drug
charge now she has upheld the remaining
18 charges his defense team meantime
taking the next step to ask Nevada's
high court to drop the remaining 18
counts he is also facing federal charges
and warrants in both Montana and out of
Canada